brazilian barbecue i [ __ ] love
brazilian barbecue yeah
they're sauces that's what people
finally agree with
oh my god all of trash tastes agreeing
on food thank you
thank you brazil they made us agree on
who knew that brazilians could bring
about world peace
i remember because i was in the first
time i had it was in japan because i had
a brazilian in my class
and they were like oh come to our bbq
we're having one and apparently there's
a place in yokohama or no tokyo bay uh
where there's like fields where you can
rent like a tent spot right next to the
tokyo like water oh
and like a picnic spot yeah and they i
think they provide the barbecue you
bring your own me yeah and they they
because uh she uh yeah she was a
a food
scientist or something somebody like
designed food or something
something of that and then she was like
she's like you have to come come try and
i was like all right okay i'll also show
up i mean yeah and they had like just
amazing food it was so good the sausage
was amazing i love sausage
is my favorite gastronomy right
i don't know that's the one something
like people would guess people would pay
her and she said that she would go to a
place like a chain or whatever and then
she would tell them how to make the food
better with science yeah or something
with science with science why didn't you
introduce me to her
mainly just like frothing at her
food
every single item at this barbecue was
amazing yeah it was like everything was
like pre-season before it went on and i
was like i feel very gonna love the
pre-season show
so i turned up ate their food and then i
was like yeah i've got to go now
oh but i actually had to go i couldn't
stay for long
yeah as much as i could it's fair enough
i remember like the
geeks plus opening party that we went to
which you unfortunately [ __ ] was not uh
because you were at the world awards i
remember i remember the food there was
like so still i still remember it they
say because it was like so unique yeah
yeah it's innovative
yeah because they they booked out like
what was it like a two-star michelin
restaurant so kataka actually invested
into a michelin well no they didn't
invest into immigration they invested in
an
innovative restaurant yeah got two stars
after like a year and a half of like
research and opening i had chipotle so
who's the girl
i'm chipotle in my box of shorts but
that restaurant is called inua and sadly
because of coronavirus it's closed
forever yeah they were very particular
about the meat they don't serve chicken
beef or pork no normal meat they don't
serve the big three
the big three
that's hunted in a specific way and
depending on where it's shot and the
side it falls it effect the blood flow
affects the meat okay now that just
seems a bit a little tube that's a bit
wanker no no no it's
in which way did the blood flow did it
flow uphill or did it flow upstream or
downstream where was the wind blowing i
just shot it i just find it hard to
believe that that could really affect it
that much it does because like the blood
cells rupture and then it contaminates
the meat where you shop well they uh the
same with fish they're not clean yeah
same with the fish same as this yeah
fish fish is like one of the most
sensitive meats i think because you can
tell when you've had all of this human
adult food
what is it other than human no because
like you can tell when you've had like
when when you have fresh fish you know
you can you can tell when it's been in
the freezer like frozen fish is like
instant like uh like yeah you can
immediately tell this you can
immediately tell from like the texture
and the taste oh like if you freeze like
a piece of chicken well i'm sad because
japan ruined fish because now i can't
eat frozen fish because now i know what
it is i never could eat frozen yeah
because that's all you it's all we
really ate
because you couldn't get that that's
that's why that's why i hated fish in
the uk
it's always frozen yeah 90 of the time
it's frozen and i just i just think it
tastes real you can taste the frozenness
and that's just like the bland frozen
taste of fish that just every person the
uk has grown up with and that's why i
hated fish until i moved to japan right
because unless 90 of it is fresh yeah
yeah because unless you actually went to
a uk restaurant where i actually shopped
in a fish market
to get fresh fish and even then you
better go into the on the day that they
went to the fish market right yeah
that's why like you if you go eat you
have to eat on like a eat fish only on
like mondays basically because that's
that's when they mostly go shop for the
fresh fish on the fish market and by
friday it's all like old yeah right
so yeah that i mean that sounds horrible
isn't your city though near the port
huh see that's a good question because
you know the uk is an island yeah we
don't eat [ __ ] fish
we card and we fry it that's about it
yeah it's kind of like why is it only
fried no you some people grill it
grilled fish isn't that common in the uk
i think i think fried is like fried fish
you can kind of hide the freshness a
little more than if it was just like
maybe put it in batter deep fryer yeah
the batter hides the fact that it was
probably really because i think a lot of
british people didn't like fish i i mean
i grew up loving uh even like canned
fish like mackerel and uh
sardines i loved i hated that i love
canned mackerel canned mackerel is so
good with baguette
uh yeah you can just shred it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love yeah that's just great yeah you
can just eat it right out of the can you
can put it on stuff it's so good
[Music]
it's so good as well because it's like
it's like one pound for like a can so
it's like oh like no no in the aldi it
was like 60 pence
and when i was trying to lose weight
that was great it was just fish i
thought it was uh broccoli and chicken
yeah yeah but sometimes you had to mix
it up for like yeah i switch it up a
little bit for lunch for lunch i make
sure i put like omelettes i do like that
yeah
okay how long have we been talking for
feels like forever uh we're recording
225.
what the [ __ ] what
what have we been talking about spoke
about food for like an hour and a half
[ __ ] my life
hope you guys enjoyed trash taste holy
[ __ ] sh i i i just i just feel like
we just we've been talking for an hour
what the [ __ ] going on well thank you
so much
[Applause]
where she speed runs all the restaurants
in japan
how can you not call it gourmet or
something along those lines i mean you
come up with so many shitty puns when
i'm with you and you refuse
yes
yes what's the shitty pun everything
that's not gourmet
that's a great username okay
i'll i'll be calling for all the viewers
to follow you yeah you know what i
haven't already you know i can't i can't
wait till we go to our next anime
convention and you actually get
recognized because you used to be just
the bookwork of run around that just
like i used to manage your guys's lines
yeah yeah you used to manage our lives
but now you're going to have now being
like are you gourmet
are you gourmet made from trash taste
maker of the boys i would start sweating
a lot
i'm sweating all the time i know yeah i
know i know i i watch i smell bad you
watch you watch what
i watch every bead of sweat let's let's
get on with that